si vous étiez un défaut vous seriez quoi
comme défaut Philippe Tesson
Philippe Tesson bonsoir bonsoir Thierry
alors Philippe Tesson vous avez déclaré
je suis d'une autre époque et c'est vrai
que vous avez en commun avec des gens
comme Jean d'Ormesson ou Daniel Toscan
Duplantier ou Stéphane Bernard
d'incarner pour moi un certain
classicisme français très 18e une façon
de d'avoir une certaine culture une
façon de l'exprimer de jouer avec les
mots avec l'esprit
voilà si vous le pensez c'est que c'est
vrai mais est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est vrai est-ce que vous vous sentez
d'une autre époque est-ce que vous
trouvez des des parenté avec des gens
comme gendarmes sans ou toscan duplantis
cette façon de manier le verbe comme on
le manier dans les dans les salons au
18e siècle on a en tout cas en commun
dans mes sons et aussi et d'autres
d'ailleurs d'être très nombreux on a en
commun de d'avoir un je pense d'un
respect très particulier pour ce que
j'appelle l'héritage oui c'est-à-dire de
ne pas refuser l'héritage c'est une
c'est vrai que c'est une tendance
contemporaine je dis pas forcément de
rejeter mais d'être extrêmement réservé
vis-à-vis du passé de la culture de
l'héritage et de ne pas être conscient
de la responsabilité que nous avons tous
de transmettre ce que nous savons de
transmettre la culture la connaissance
issue du passé à la aux gens qui
représentent le présent et l'avenir
alors attendez Philippe parce que je le
connais moi de caisson en bosse ensemble
pour une autre chaîne si vous parlez
trop c'est ça
[Musique]
du sentiment que chaque individu a dans
une démocratie vis-à-vis de la société
lui au contraire Geoffrin il pense que
c'est une nouvelle étape dans la
conquête de la liberté cette perte
d'autorité cette disparition de
l'autorité à peu près partout lui pense
que c'est une nouvelle conquête une
nouvelle étape en fait c'est un peu
comme les mecs qui disent le vert est
admis plein de milite quoi vous êtes
plutôt du genre il est admis admis vide
et lui admis plein quoi le problème de
l'équilibre d'une société je peux pas
être trop abstrait mais c'est
l'équilibre entre la mesure entre
l'autorité qui est une nécessité et puis
la liberté qui est un rêve voilà alors
je frappe offre le luxe d'être du côté
du rêve et moi qui suis un petit peu
plus âgé je suis plutôt du côté de je
dis pas de l'ordre mais du côté de la
nécessité une société qui obéit pas
cette nécessité est une société qui va à
sa perte qu'est-ce que vous croyez pas
que finalement aujourd'hui vous avez
cette position simplement par
déterminisme social c'est-à-dire vous
dites je suis bourgeois d'origine et de
formation donc finalement est-ce que
c'est pas excusez-moi je crois que c'est
ni fait rien je crois que ça lui fait
mais strictement rien je connais des
gens ne sont pas d'origine bourgeoise et
qui vont beaucoup plus loin que moi dans
la défense de ce qui est convenu
d'appeler l'ordre social et je connais
etchant coller beaucoup et vous aussi
Thierry énormément de bourgeois qui vont
très loin dans la défense du laxisme et
de la et de la liberté mal comprises
vous êtes d'accord oui bien alors vous
pensez pas qu'aujourd'hui la seule
autorité finalement qui risque de rester
ça va être l'argent
il y a une chose qui fait autorité
aujourd'hui je le déplande d'ailleurs
c'est le marché le marché et s'il n'y a
pas une vraie crise de l'autorité dans
l'entreprise c'est parce que il y a une
loi objective fondamentale forte
irrépressible qui s'appelle le marché on
le dit d'ailleurs dans tous les journaux
le marché fait la loi combien de fois on
utilise cette expression alors si le
marché fait la loi ça veut dire qu'il y
a une loi et que tout le monde doit s'y
soumettre
à ses dépens ou à son profit et que ce
soit c'est une émission fils de divorcée
et Jean contre le marché
très bien on est à la lumière on finit
interview je sais pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc vous vous avez
l'interview c'est ça qu'il faut employer
le mauvais mot
donc vous avez connu la guerre
vous dites même que vous avez lu
l'histoire à l'hiver enfin c'est une
expression qu'on emploie première
question pendant la guerre est-ce que
les FFI étaient des terroristes ou des
résistants
il faut employer le mauvais mot
on éteint la lumière en fait chinois
juste pour voir un peu plus
[Musique]
il y a pas bien qui est fatigué
une fleur je serai à myosotis bon là
c'est lentille portrait chinois donc
évidemment c'est pas des fleurs si vous
étiez un défaut vous seriez quoi comme
défaut Philippe Tesson
c'est à dire comment je me vois comment
je me vois si vous étiez un défaut
je rejette la question c'est pas assez
c'est pas envisageable c'est pas
possible
la question là vous devez des mauvaises
vous donner des mauvaises habitudes aux
invités suivants c'est pas possible si
vous étiez une injure
personne n'a jamais rejeté de questions
si vous étiez simplement que c'est
impossible à envisager c'est une
hypothèse impossible si vous étiez une
injure j'étais une injure j'étais une
injure si je vous assuriez si je voulais
vous injuriez je vous dirai Thierry
bravo je suis d'accord avec vous vous
êtes le plus fort
pour vous la flagornerie c'est la pire
injure
certainement j'hésite pas une seconde
l'indigestion par excès de gourmandise
si vous étiez une perversion
si j'étais une perversion je serai ici
et je jouerai à votre petit jeu si vous
étiez une guerre
gardez l'air si vous étiez un vice
la lecture puisque c'est ta vie un puni
c'est le seul si vous étiez une arme
une arme
fatale une arme secrète une arme secrète
si vous étiez un supplice
une page blanche
c'est très bien vous étiez un poison
c'est mieux que d'habitude c'est pas
vrai Adriana
si vous étiez une humiliation
la différence
une torture
le petit feu mais pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de tube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu